This is,
as I said,
my last lecture for this course,
and I'm entitling this lecture,
uh,
the democratization of finance.
Uh,
I wanted to save this to the end because it's really about looking at the broad
purpose of,
of our financial markets and our financial institutions.
Um,
and ultimately the,
there's only one purpose,
uh,
to all of us.
And that's human welfare.
Uh,
it's people,
and this should be obvious,
but,
uh,
let's not forget that,
corporations exist only for the benefit of people.
Normally we say for their owners,
but we could also add other stakeholders,
but it's people,
individual people that matter and only lets you want to add animals.
But we have nonprofits that are aimed at animal welfare as well,
so including them.
Um,
so,
uh,
I've made it a theme of my recent books that finance is a powerful tool for
improving human welfare.
Um,
and,
uh,
in my,
latest two books,
I emphasize what I call the democratization of finance.
Maybe I should write this down because it's a term that I like to use.
Um,
democratization
of finance.
Uh,
or you can say for short financial democracy,
but I mean,
something a little different.
Uh,
in the 1930s,
people talked about financial democracy as,
um,
the shareholders,
shareholders voting for the direction of a corporation.
I don't mean by that,
by democratization of finance.
I mean bringing it to the people.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
Deimos,
there's been a long trend towards a democratization of finance that goes back
centuries.
And that is,
uh,
it originally financial techniques where we're of a value only to the very rich
are the very sophisticated.
Um,
in
1780,
the president of Harvard College had his paycheck.
I think it was president of Lamont indexed to inflation.
Uh,
I've been trying to figure out if anyone else in the world had ever had a CPI
index labor contract.
Uh,
and I,
I've not been able to discover any other example that was 1780.
So there was one person in the world who had an inflation index,
uh,
employment contract and funny,
who was it?
It was the president of Harford.
And so not the random person.
Um,
but as time goes by,
we have more and more spread of these concepts.
And,
uh,
so I make it as a mission and,
in two of my books,
new financial earner,
which is on reserve and my new book,
which I'm right here,
sub prime solution,
uh,
which is not unreasonable because I haven't finished it yet,
but it will be out.
Uh,
and it will be sometime this summer.
It will be available in bookstores.
And apparently,
uh,
well,
so the theme is that
in both of these books is that a lot of our problems can be solved by,
um,
by ex extent continuing this trend towards,
uh,
democratization of finance.
So,
uh,
we have problems with inequality.
Economic inequality
is,
I think probably the most important issue facing advanced countries today.
And that is that,
uh,
we are not sharing income equally.
There are a remarkable number of poor people,
uh,
and a small,
very elite group who are making hundreds of millions of dollars.
And in most countries of the world,
inequality is getting worse.
This applies both to the advanced countries like the United States and to the
emerging countries.
Like China and India
is not altogether bad because part of the reason inequality is getting worse is
that there are suddenly getting rich people.
And,
uh,
if,
if everyone's getting better off,
you could say what's the problem?
In many ways that is the,
uh,
the right answer.
But I think that we can't tolerate excessive inequality.
The beauty of it is that the very same capitalism that has been generating
inequality has solutions for it.
Uh,
and many of our venerable economic institutions that we already have are working
against any quality.
So,
uh,
I mentioned just for example,
life insurance
that helps alleviate any quality by eliminating one important cause of
inequality.
A lot of poor people traditionally are people who've lost a families that have
lost one of the two parents,
uh,
either the mother or the father.
And of course that puts the family in stress because they have just lost half of
their,
uh,
adults.
Uh,
if you have life insurance that solves that,
um,
another source of inequality is solved by health insurance.
An important cause of inequality is somebody gets sick.
Uh,
and,
um,
so they,
they are unable to earn an income and they end up in disastrous economic
situation.
Another one is disability insurance.
Okay.
Disability insurance protects you against something like,
uh,
an accident that causes you to become unable to hold a job.
And,
uh,
that tends to be a lifetime thing.
Disability insurance is a lifetime insurance contract.
You pay for it while you're healthy.
If you become disabled,
you get,
uh,
support for the rest of your life.
So these are just some examples of how inequality is already being dealt with
through risk management institutions and why?
Uh,
uh,
finance,
I always lump insurance.
These are all insurance,
but I lump that in with finance says risk management and why they're so
important.
Um,
but,
uh,
we still see any quality getting worse.
And so I think that is a challenge toward improving our risk management
institutions.
The subprime crisis that we're in now is really substantially due to failures of
our risk management institutions.
Uh,
notably,
well,
we have had a failure to provide institutions to help people to diversify their
own household portfolios.
So people who,
um,
uh,
bought a house would have been in a highly leveraged position,
and,
uh,
vulnerable to risks of changes in home prices and the other risks.
So,
um,
uh,
so we need to go a lot further.
Now,
part of this theme of democratization of finance is that right?
Um,
we have to pay respect to behavioral finance.
Uh,
and that's because people don't,
uh,
especially the less educated or less capable people.
Don't always,
yeah.
Make optimal use of financial instruments,
uh,
like,
for example,
insurance.
Uh,
so,
um,
if people don't make use of,
of risk management contracts,
then,
uh,
we have a problem.
So what we have to do going forward in the future is designed our risk
management contracts to work better for real people.
All right?
And so that requires a,
what they call in the engineering department,
human factors
engineering.
But I'll add financial,
financial engineering as a term,
sometimes used in a disparaging term for people who invent things that are just
a bit too complicated.
But usually the word financial engineering is used approvingly to refer to
people's efforts to make finance work.
Uh,
even better than before,
uh,
to make progress in our financial institution.
So one of the themes of my,
of the,
of this book and this book is that,
uh,
we have a lot of progress to be made and,
but I think it has to be taking account of our better or a better financial
institutions,
uh,
knowledge of financial theory and behavior.
So what I wanted to talk about actually w this lecture,
I have several parts that I wanted to talk first about,
um,
about social insurance,
which is not normally covered in a finance course,
but it seems to be so relevant that I want to talk about it.
Social insurance refers to government programs,
uh,
that insure people against risk.
Uh,
and so I wanted to talk about the extremely important risk management programs
that the government has instituted a talk,
especially about bankruptcy and bailouts because they're relevant right now,
particularly relevant right now with the subprime crisis.
Um,
and then I wanted to conclude this lecture with,
uh,
some thoughts about financial careers and about morality.
Um,
I wanted to,
I talked about that in the first lecture.
Maybe I should have talked more consistently about it,
but,
um,
young people are thinking about careers and I think that ultimately I give you
credit for wondering about the moral purpose of different careers.
I think finance has a somewhat tarnished reputation,
uh,
but I think that's really miss,
undeserved,
uh,
um,
I guess people finance get into controversial
positions,
uh,
more so than people who are in other occupations that don't put them in these
moral dilemmas.
And sometimes they can behave badly.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I don't actually claim to have answers.
You should take a philosophy course,
however,
won't give you answers to all these ethical questions.
But what I want to do is at least a raise them and
think a little bit about,
uh,
how they relate to this course.
Okay.
So the first principle of,
uh,
of,
um,
I want to come back now to what I said I would talk about namely the role of the
government and risk management.
Uh,
uh,
and I think it would be a mistake to ignore this because,
David Moss who is actually,
uh,
got his phd in history from Yale and I talked to him when he was still here.
You want a book,
uh,
when all else fails.
Yes.
And it was a history of risk management in the u s uh,
this is about 10 years ago.
This book came,
or eight years,
I forget exactly,
sometime in the last decade.
Um,
and he makes the argument that really every government,
he,
he's,
he focuses on the u s but every government has a risk management role and much
of what governments do is to,
uh,
is to do risk management,
especially modern governments.
That wasn't maybe true so much,
uh,
before,
before the end of the 19th century.
But governments have gotten an increasingly and,
uh,
into risk management.
The first,
um,
uh,
example I would give is the progressive income tax
or graduated a graduated income tax as it was called by Adam Smith
in 1776.
And his book,
the wealth of nations.
He said that maybe we should have a tax on income and the tax on income should
be graduated so that people with higher incomes pay a higher fraction of their
income and that would help reduce inequality.
Um,
but Smith,
although he raised it in that famous book in 1776,
he then quickly dismissed it as unworkable because he said if we had an income
tax,
it would be quote,
a tax on conscience,
meaning that only the honest people would pay it because it was impossible to
verify any income.
Uh,
income is too complicated to measure.
uh,
so,
maybe he was right.
The first income tax,
uh,
it was either
the UK or Holland,
um,
around,
uh,
at the end of the 18th century,
they had small income taxes and they were,
they were progressive.
Uh,
but they were beginning,
the u s experimented with an income tax in the 1860s,
uh,
and abandoned it.
The original experiments where all,
I'm only marginally successful,
but the u s finally got an income tax in 1913,
uh,
and at a very low level,
but,
uh,
this is the u s uh,
it ultimately became very important.
It,
uh,
after a World War II,
the top marginal tax bracket right rose above 90%.
So it became a very significant redistributor of income.
And ultimately it's gone way back down.
Now we've reversed it.
Uh,
but ultimately it,
it's a risk management device.
What it means is that,
uh,
if,
if you do very poorly,
you don't pay any taxes and you get benefits,
uh,
and,
um,
uh,
we also,
I might add to it,
we have a progressive income tax that finances
education for everyone,
universal education and other social services and public goods.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so that is a risk management device and it works despite limitations of human
behavior because
it's automatic.
It's imposed on you so nobody can forget about it.
It becomes a universal risk management device.
In some sense.
It's the most important risk management device of all because it deals at the
very low level.
Uh,
starting in around that,
uh,
well I guess you could go back to Milton Friedman who was a conservative
economist who started advocating a negative income tax in the 1940s,
but he actually,
um,
in his 1963 bucks
a capitalism and freedom,
the advocated at more strong,
that's the usual source that we should have a negative tax on low income people
to bring their income up to a,
uh,
a good substantial level.
So,
uh,
that was the negative income tax.
Uh,
and it sounded like a very,
uh,
negative tax on low income.
It sounded like a very,
uh,
controversial,
crazy idea when he launched it.
But crazy ideas have a way of eventually becoming standard.
Uh,
and the United States,
uh,
adopted and it is now fairly significant,
something called the earned income tax credit,
which is a negative income tax for low income families.
So,
uh,
emerged from thinking.
So
e I t c earned income tax credit.
If you are a family with children,
uh,
with income very low,
um,
like under 10,000,
you'll get a substantial negative tax.
It's several thousand dollars.
Um,
and that is risk management.
It means that anybody who's income falls below a very low is a,
it's kind of like an income insurance scheme run by the government.
Um,
the concern about all of these schemes,
however,
its moral hazard,
uh,
and,
if you have an earned income tax credit,
uh,
it,
it's kind of designed around moral hazard.
Uh,
instead of having welfare,
welfare is a,
uh,
is a less,
that's just a gift to someone who doesn't have any job at all,
who has no income.
Then that moral welfare,
uh,
tends to lead to a moral hazard problem.
If the government says,
if you don't have a job,
we'll support you.
That encourages people to say,
okay,
I don't have a job.
Uh,
but the earned income tax credit is different because it's a negative tax rate
on your income.
So you have to have income in order to get anything.
So you have to get a job to get the EITC,
and the more you earn,
the more he ITC up to a limit for low levels of income,
the more negative tax you get.
So,
uh,
it's the thing that we're doing.
What we're doing as time goes by as we're getting a clearer picture of how to,
uh,
design risk management contacts,
contracts for the general public.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the ITC was invented in the 70s.
It was in the U S it was sponsored by Senator Russell Long and it is now being
copied around the world,
although I guess there were earlier antecedents,
but at the urs was the first country to do a AITC.
Uh,
the other I wanted just to remind you of the different kinds of risk management
that the government,
um,
and one important,
uh,
ask one important part of it is social security.
Uh,
I want to go back to the original social security system.
and it was in Germany that under Otto von Bismarck that the first social
security systems were developed,
uh,
and it was considered a highly radical idea in the 1880s.
When I put this down in German in case some of you,
um,
can,
can understand this.
Uh,
18,
83,
fracking,
physical wrong,
that's one word,
but I've run out of room.
Health insurance was founded nationally in Germany.
It was a government mandatory program.
Everybody in Germany had to contribute to health insurance.
Uh,
I'll write this over.
German words are very long.
They run them together and I ran out of room to write Cronk and visit her wrong.
Um,
in,
uh,
um,
he teen 84
one fall fairs echo wrong one means accident like a fall
for Zika.
Wrong means insurance.
The government created an accident referring to workplace accident insurance.
Uh,
and it was the German government had it.
it was an arrangement that made it mandatory for employers to buy insurance
against injuries to people who work there.
Uh,
and then three,
um,
uh,
they had an 1889 tears for a zipper on it.
This isn't supposed to be a German lesson and I can get it right,
right.
It right.
I,
but I like to put it this way because it suggested its origin.
This was old age insurance.
Altera means old.
Uh,
and so,
um,
old age insurance was generated for the whole country of Germany.
And at this point in 1889,
Germany was the only country to have a social insurance program.
So around shortly after the turn of the century,
Lloyd George,
who was prime minister of the UK,
traveled to Germany and,
uh,
was looked at their system and it was very much impressed and thought.
He said one thing I noticed,
Germany,
there are no beggars normally in London.
You couldn't walk down the street without seeing somebody who was sitting there
holding out a Tin Cup who had no legs or,
or,
uh,
our mothers with children who are orphans.
And,
uh,
and he said,
it's gone in Germany.
So he was,
became convinced that UK should follow the lead.
This was copied over the whole world,
and it's virtually everywhere now.
I mean,
some less developed countries haven't gotten there yet,
but this is where they're going.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I wanted to quote Gustaf smaller,
who is a German economist in the 1880s,
uh,
smaller,
in the early 20th century.
He wrote some memoirs,
uh,
and uh,
about his life and the life of other economists in Germany.
And he said the triumph of insurance in every imaginable area era,
I,
sorry,
area was one of the centuries,
meaning the 19th centuries,
great advances in social progress.
It was an entirely logical development that insurance spread from the upper
classes to the lower classes that had had to attempt as far as possible to
eliminate poverty.
And that the older charitable relief funds for the workers were more and more
constructed on the sound principle of insurance.
The problem with charity is that it tends to be whimsical and capricious.
If you're relying on charity to resolve problems of poverty,
it's going to be applied very unevenly.
Uh,
and uh,
it,
it would be salient examples of poverty.
Like if a child is suddenly stricken with some unusual illness and it gets
written up in the newspapers,
then generous contributions would come pouring in to that child.
But other children who are not so blessed,
uh,
get nothing,
in the United States,
uh,
we were about the last country to jump onto the bandwagon began in Germany.
Uh,
it's partly,
I guess because the U s is more free enterprise,
uh,
and its orientation.
Maybe it doesn't like to adopt ideas from Europe.
Uh,
it wasn't until the Great Depression that the u s adopted,
uh,
Alterra is physic around.
Uh,
and we still haven't adopted Karkin for his or her.
We still don't have a national health insurance.
We have Medicare and Medicaid,
but they don't apply to everyone.
So we have about 40 million uninsured Americans with no health insurance.
So we're still not there yet.
Maybe we'll get there.
Um,
but I wanted to talk about some of the,
uh,
important,
is that,
um,
uh,
so the social security system
in the u s is our copy of the German system.
Uh,
and,
uh,
social security started in 1935,
so that was about 50 years after the Germans invented.
Uh,
and it's remarkable how similar the idea that we've done it and it,
and it stays.
We really have something like the 1889 German system in place today.
What it,
what it did is it created a system of contributions,
uh,
to this right now.
Uh,
when you get a job,
you have to pay 6.2%.
Uh,
uh,
that's on your pay stub.
6.2% is taken out as your contribution to social security.
Uh,
and then your employer pays another 6.2.
So 12.4% of your income goes to social security.
And those are thought of as contributions to an insurance scheme for your,
it has three components.
It's called o as the actually
oh a stands for old age.
A,
uh,
s stands for our survivors
and Dai sends for disability insurance,
but they're all insurance.
So you are ma,
it's mandatory.
You are paying a lot into this system.
You're paying the fact that your employer pays half of it is perhaps misleading.
So it's really like 12% of your income is forced to go into an insurance gift.
That's big.
Now that there's a cutoff though,
after you reached,
I think it's around 95,000,
uh,
you don't have to pay any more.
But for most people it's 12% of their income is going to social security.
And what do they get for it?
They get a pension when they're old and it's guaranteed for the rest of your
life.
And these other things a lot of people don't even know about you don't even know
that you've got the survivor's insurance is a life insurance program.
This was actually added in 1939 two with amendments.
I guess maybe disability was added at that time too.
What it means is if you are a under a certain age,
I think it's 18,
if your parents die,
the government will give,
will a or one of your parents dies,
a government will pay money to the family to support you.
It's life insurance offered by the government.
And why did the government get into this?
Well,
the problem was it's behavioral finance again,
that uh,
while wealthy people tended to get life insurance,
the general mass of people were not,
uh,
because of some behavioral problem.
They just didn't,
the value of it didn't understand it.
Disability insurance means that if you're,
if you work and you have an accident and then you can no longer work,
you start collecting social security.
Normally you don't get the old age until the age of 62 or 65.
Um,
but a disability you can get at any age if you become disabled.
You know,
it's funny that I think a lot of people don't even know they have this.
These institutions operate so quietly.
Partly the government,
they call this survivor's insurance.
When they created it in 1939 I was wondering,
why don't they call it life insurance?
That's what it is.
Life insurance is something that pays the survivors of a family member who dies.
I think they didn't want to call it life insurance because they didn't want to
threaten the industry.
There's a whole life insurance industry.
The government was going in a big way to create a product which is mandatory.
They didn't want to upset the life.
And so they called it something different.
And you can get a life insurance salesman who will sell you life insurance and
not even mention that you've got a policy already,
whether you want it or not.
Uh,
they would just be offering something to add to the,
uh,
what,
what uh,
also they did starting in the 1930s,
um,
it was,
uh,
was originally called,
aid to dependent children or they change it to aid to families
with dependent children.
That was a separate program beyond,
these parents didn't have to be,
uh,
didn't have to be disabled and uh,
or old or anything like that to get this.
Um,
uh,
and so that started in 1935.
That's our welfare system.
It was a for parents that couldn't earn enough money.
You know,
if you have a mother,
a single mother with no husband,
uh,
and the husband or the husband just can't make any money,
she would get aid for herself and the children,
um,
that however,
was abolished in 1996,
uh,
because of moral hazard,
the,
uh,
the aid to families with dependent children was created in 1935 with little,
attention to the amount of moral hazard it might eventually create.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
we there grew a increasing problem of welfare dependency.
Uh,
you would have families that had lived on,
uh,
AFTC their whole lives and their grandfather parent's lives and their
grandparents lives.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
public opinion turned against that.
And so it was in 1996 a and we had a,
a welfare reform act,
uh,
that abolished AFDC.
Um,
it was a republican bill,
uh,
but it was signed by the Democratic president,
Carter Clinton.
So
that eliminated a federal,
whether essentially they ended the welfare program started in the depression.
Um,
there they are,
there still is some welfare,
but there's a lifetime,
five year limit
on an actual welfare.
So after you've been collecting it for five years,
you are disqualified.
And it denied welfare to immigrants who are not citizens.
Uh,
and it,
uh,
limited,
food stamps to unemployed childless adults.
Uh,
so it,
uh,
I think there's a there as we move ahead.
Uh,
we're becoming increasingly aware of how to design a institutions around human
glitches.
And so the welfare reform act,
I don't know if it was the right policy,
but it was trying to eliminate a moral hazard problem.
Um,
so we have,
instead of,
we've replaced the aid to families with dependent children with a more generous
AITC and you see that it has very different moral hazard implications to get
earned income tax credit.
You've got to have a job and it can't just be a token job because you don't,
it's,
it has the negative tactics as a function of your income.
I take this as signs of past progress that that will,
um,
that will continue in the future.
Um,
so I wanted to talk about bankruptcy briefly here because that is something
that's,
uh,
I mentioned is a very important risk management device,
and its relevance right now in time of financial crises.
So,
uh,
the United States did not have a bankruptcy law at the federal level,
generally until 1,898.
But during the 19th century,
there were repeated financial crises that,
uh,
led to temporary bankruptcy laws.
What happened was like what we're seeing right now,
there was some financial crisis and it caused people to lose their jobs,
uh,
for no fault of their own and they couldn't pay their debts.
Uh,
and laws back then were often very harsh and it would send people to debtor's
prison.
But,
uh,
I think the enlightened view gradually developed,
this is crazy.
You know,
some person is,
is trying hard,
there's a big financial crisis,
makes bad investments,
uh,
then it can't pay debts and we put this guy in jail.
Uh,
that's crazy.
In fact,
there should be some other,
um,
other method that,
uh,
that deals better with bankruptcy.
So,
um,
uh,
it was,
there were numerous bankruptcy laws,
but,
uh,
normal was the 1841 law,
which for a temporary period gave,
this is after a financial crisis,
gave a fresh start.
They said someone declaring bankruptcy can wipe out all debts and not go to
jail.
And uh,
as long as they draw their wealth down to zero,
they could have a fresh start and go back to life.
Normally.
That kind of idea has gradually been,
uh,
and it's now,
now it's a part of her general assumption about bankruptcies.
Um,
I mentioned that 1898 was the landmark bankruptcy law.
And this is the first time that we had bankruptcy in shrine as an institution
that lasts all the time.
It's not just during financial crisis.
You can at anytime declared bankruptcy as a way to protect yourself.
Uh,
and uh,
there was another landmark.
This is a landmark bankruptcy law.
Uh,
and there was another one in 1978,
uh,
another landmark bankruptcy bill,
which made it even easier,
much easier for people to declare bankruptcy.
Uh,
and as a result,
especially after 1978,
bankruptcies became very commonly used ways to manage extreme outcomes in one's
a finances.
And in fact,
recently since in 1978,
uh,
there's,
typically over a million bankruptcies,
personal bankruptcies a year.
It's a little known fact that there are more bankruptcies than divorces.
And you may wonder,
well,
how can that be?
I don't hear about bankruptcies.
You hear about divorces all the time.
Uh,
I think the reason that you don't hear about bankruptcies is that nobody needs
to tell you.
You know,
you don't come across saying,
Hey,
you know what?
He asked someone what's new?
Oh,
I just declared bankruptcy.
They don't do that.
They don't do that about divorces either.
But the problem with divorces as they can't cover it up,
everybody knows you've gotten a divorce.
So we hear a lot more about them.
But bankruptcies are,
are very important.
The other bill that,
uh,
is very important as 2005
and that reverses some of the 1978 a bill.
So,
uh,
we've been pulling back maybe in 1978 was too generous,
but I just wanted to give you some clue about,
uh,
about what bankruptcy is there.
If you,
there's three important kinds of bankruptcy and they refer to chapters of the
United States code.
There's chapter seven bankruptcy.
You should know this because half of you are going to declare bankruptcy
someday.
No,
maybe not.
We hope that you get an education in finance and few of you will declare
bankruptcy,
but some of you are going to be going through this,
uh,
chapter 11 and chapter 13.
So just so you are now,
uh,
in advance before you actually do those.
Um,
chapter seven is a liquidation form.
And this is where you say this is that this is a fresh start.
And Story.
You give up everything you have to your creditors,
the bankruptcy court will divide it up among,
um,
among the creditors.
And then you have a fresh start,
a,
it used to be in 1978.
You could do this every six years,
but as I remember it,
2005 thought 1978 was too lenient,
so they moved it to every eight years.
Uh,
so that's what you can do.
if you are in big trouble,
you've gotten in more depth than you can handle.
What you have to do is go to a lawyer and file for bankruptcy.
And a chapter seven is often the favorite thing because it gives you a fresh
start.
Uh,
however,
the 2005 law said that you can't do as an individual,
you can't do chapter seven unless your income is below the median for your
state.
So,
uh,
I guess you have to forget chapter seven,
I'm assuming that most of you will be making more than the median income for the
state you live in.
So Cross chapter seven,
unless you were really in bad situation,
a cross chapter seven or chapter seven is for chapter 11.
Uh,
but companies can also do chapter seven chapter 11 is for companies,
uh,
and it,
it's a reorganization rather than liquid.
It's a liquid liquidation.
Uh,
and for companies that it's,
it's a system to help them get back on their feet.
When you,
when a company files for chapter 11 bankruptcy,
what they're saying is,
hey,
we can't pay,
we're out of money and we have all these people coming to us that we owe money
to and we don't know who to pay first.
You know,
we just don't have enough money.
It becomes a disorderly process.
Uh,
and so they go to the court for protection.
W when a company runs out of money and it can't pay its bills,
then that can destroy the company immediately because people who were delivering
things to the company that they need,
we'll stop delivering them.
They say,
I hear you're bankrupt.
You're not going to pay us.
So we're going to stop delivering and that can destroy the company.
So the idea of chapter 11 is to keep the company going.
So the court would impose some order and allow the company to continue in
business and to hold off the creditors for now.
And it is ultimately in the creditor's interest if they,
if the court does this because they're better off in getting their debts paid if
the company is still making money.
Chapter 13 is something like chapter 11,
as for individuals
and chapter 13,
that's the one you're,
you're going to be filing,
put it that way.
Some of you will be filing for chapter 13 bankruptcy.
Uh,
and what it is,
is that the court,
the bankruptcy court will,
uh,
adjust,
make adjustments and a plan for you to pay off the debts.
Uh,
and this is what we hope to see happen in increasing number of cases during the
current crisis.
So somebody has taken out a big mortgage,
uh,
they've taken out car loans and they were kind of profit yet and now there's a
problem and they can't pay on all these.
So they declare chapter 13 to get a lawyer to represent them and the court can
adjust.
Um,
can adjust their debts.
Uh,
but not to eliminate them.
It says right now in federal bankruptcy law that they cannot adjust the mortgage
on your house,
but they can adjust other debts.
This is something that we're talking about.
The congress is talking about changing because the mortgage on the house is a
big debt that,
uh,
that bankruptcy ought to be able to adjust.
It hasn't happened yet.
I wanted to mention something else,
just so you understand what bankruptcy is.
There's something called informal bankruptcy.
And what's the difference with bankruptcy?
A bankruptcy is for people who have enough foresight to hire a lawyer and go out
a year.
If,
you know,
if,
if you are having trouble paying your bills,
you know enough to go and hire a lawyer and the lawyer might demand a little
money up front,
you know,
there has to be paid.
So it,
you should stop paying your bills and accumulate at least a thousand dollars.
So you can go to a lawyer and start chapter 13 bankruptcy proceedings.
Uh,
but most,
a lot of people don't have the ability to save $1,000,
uh,
or the,
you know,
the figure this out and they won't call a lawyer.
So what is it common thing somebody is running up too much in credit card bills,
loses a job,
creditors start calling.
What do you think happens?
They don't get a lawyer.
That's what they do.
They stop answering the phone.
All right,
very simple.
I've run off all these debts.
The phone keeps ringing in these nasty people keep annoying me.
So I just stopped using the,
in fact,
I let my whole phone bill lapsed.
I don't pay my phone bill.
I don't even have a phone anymore,
so no one can come and get the knock on my door and I don't answer the door.
Uh,
so what did the courts do?
What creditors do in the various states?
They can go to a state court and uh,
appeal to the court to Garnish your salary and you don't have to do anything.
You don't have to show up.
They go to,
they find out who your employer is,
they,
and then the state gives an order for the employer to take money out of your
paycheck to help pay your debts.
You never even figured out what happened.
In fact,
you might not even know it because you don't read your pay stub.
And now some of your money is going to garnishment of your salary.
Uh,
that's not,
uh,
that happens.
Uh,
but see,
this is the reality of,
um,
of,
uh,
of bankruptcy.
Um,
so we are talking about,
uh,
another revision of the bankruptcy bill,
because we're in a serious crisis and maybe 2005 pulled back to much,
we keep waffling about how tight we want these.
But ultimately,
bankruptcy law is very important in risk management because this is big time
risk management.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it has to be adjusted to deal with moral hazard.
And other thing I just wanted to mention right now,
there's a bill being proposed by our own senator,
Chris Dodd,
uh,
here from Connecticut and Barney Frank,
which is not a bankruptcy bill.
It's a bill,
a bailout.
They don't call it a bailout bill.
They say it's not a bail out,
but I call it a bailout bill,
uh,
to help people who can't pay their mortgages and they don't have to declare
bankruptcy.
Uh,
what they're wanting to do is to empower the federal housing administration to
guarantee loans,
to work out loans and guaranteed him,
uh,
so it's workout.
And then an Fha guarantee loans.
So you don't have to declare a bank,
you just have to go,
uh,
to your mortgage lender and say,
I can't pay,
I'd like one of these FHA workouts.
And then if this hasn't happened yet,
this is a bill.
But if this bill passes,
then they would be the,
they said,
and maybe several hundred billion dollars of mortgages would be guaranteed.
So here's the typical story might be you owe $300,000 on your house,
or maybe that's too big.
You are 100,000 on your house.
They might lower that to 90,000,
uh,
and give a different payment schedule.
And then,
uh,
the,
Fha,
well tell the bank that if you do this well to the bank,
if you make these adjustments,
we will guarantee the mortgage.
So this is another,
um,
that,
that is that the federal government will pay back the mortgage if the individual
doesn't,
the government is getting into risk management,
they're managing the risks to the mortgage lenders.
Uh,
so,
uh,
in my,
are just mentioned,
one of the ideas that my book sub prime solution,
uh,
I'm thinking that this,
these things have happened in history.
So many times we've had bankruptcy bills,
we've had bailouts of one sort or another.
Uh,
they're very controversial because people say,
luckily there's a moral hazard problem if we're bailing out homeowners who
didn't pay their mortgage.
Isn't that a bad thing?
We're,
uh,
and,
and also we're doing it after the fact.
Uh,
nobody explained this to the borrowers that they'd be getting this bailout.
So isn't that unfair to,
uh,
maybe other people who didn't buy a house who are more,
you know,
more sensible?
Uh,
so what,
what I am proposing and sub prime solution is that,
uh,
we just have these bailouts are important and we have to make them work better.
Uh,
and so I have something which I call a continuous workout mortgage,
which we should move to.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this is,
my idea.
So I just mentioned one of the ideas in my book,
the way Dodd Frank is proposing it,
is that people who are in difficulty would have a single workout.
It's just like a banquet.
Bankruptcy is a single event occurs only once every eight years.
So people who are in big trouble yet,
uh,
get help from the government,
but then it's a onetime only big event and it only every eight years.
So,
um,
why don't we do it continuously?
Uh,
and so what we want to do is have a mortgage.
So the balance or the payments adjust automatically,
uh,
for changes in home prices
or incomes.
Uh,
and,
and so,
um,
that would,
uh,
that would make it a,
you get a workout every month.
Uh,
now that sounds kind of radical and strange,
but I don't see why we shouldn't do that.
Especially if we can get markets for home prices and incomes so that the,
uh,
the lenders can hedge the risk.
I'm talking about private institutions offering mortgages that build in the kind
of workouts that we're doing on an emergency basis from time to time.
Once he recognized that workouts are needed,
why don't we make it part of the structure and institution.
Anyway,
that's just a little story.
What I'm doing in my book,
I said I would conclude this lecture with some thoughts and I have like 15
minutes for thoughts about,
uh,
how about finance.
Um,
and I wanted particularly to a aim at,
at,
uh,
people at your stage in the lifecycle,
young,
younger people.
Um,
because,
um,
as I said at the beginning,
there's a,
I think people at your age are rightly concerned about purpose in life.
You are launching out onto a whole lifetime career.
And,
uh,
I don't know how you feel.
Uh,
I'm just guessing that a lot of the things that you might be doing it seem
possibly meaningless or,
or at least not having enough meaning or purpose.
Um,
and I think that's a good thing to worry about.
Most of the time you're taking a job,
you're taking a job to do some task that somebody wants done,
and it may be hard to see how it figures into some global picture,
but,
um,
but people want to do some something.
That's good.
I wanted to come back,
first of all to a theme that I mentioned in the,
in the first lecture.
Uh,
and that was,
uh,
I think it's a remarkable book.
I,
I'll,
I'll put it on reserve.
Right.
I don't,
I don't think I actually got it on reserve.
Yeah.
But,
um,
uh,
Peter Unger is a philosopher and his mark is called living high.
Okay.
And letting dye,
uh,
that was 1996.
Uh,
and what,
this is a book about what we do and our lives,
namely,
that we tend to be wrapped up in ourselves,
right.
Um,
does,
uh,
in advanced countries like the U S we're living pretty well,
but in other places that people are starving or how are in desperate situations.
One of the moral dilemmas that we seem to face is that,
um,
you could save lives anytime you want by just giving to one of the appropriate
charity.
So I'll write this down again,
this is on the first,
I'm repeating it.
I said this in the first lecture,
but it's worth repeating.
And the first page of his book,
uh,
he has done a address to mail,
but you wouldn't mail anymore.
I'll put it down again.
H t t p a slash slash w w w.
Dot.
UNICEF that com a.org.
Sorry.
Or that's,
uh,
the United Nations Children's Fund support
a slash index dot.
H T m e l,
a,
that's their website.
And he is saying,
why don't you put this book down now,
right now and send a check for $100 to UNICEF.
And he estimates that that will save 33 lives of children in the world.
I actually got on the NSF website this morning to check this out.
They claim that they have 9.7 million,
9.7 million children die every year for preventable causes,
uh,
for things that are preventable through vaccinations and,
improve water supply and the things that they do,
but they don't have enough money to do.
The reason I write this down,
actually,
I don't know what you would do it.
I was reading the book,
I was wondering,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of a shock.
They put this down and think I could save live by just a check for $100.
Uh,
and I didn't do it.
And so I thought,
you know,
that really made an impression on me because I just continued to read the book
and I never,
so finally when I rewrote it,
the third time I got on the website and I contributed $100.
So I,
but then I,
then I had this moral dilemma,
why did I stop at a $100 because I can go way beyond $100 and have all these
people are dying.
Why am I not doing that?
Uh,
and,
uh,
and so you start to think of justifications and excuses that come to your mind.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
and maybe don't want to read this book because he shoots them all down,
all these justifications.
Uh,
one of the,
um,
one of the justifications is futility.
You say,
well,
these poor people in these less developed countries,
you really can't help them anyway because,
uh,
it'll all get lost or the population will increase and there'll be more dying
people.
So anyway,
he dismisses that you have to read it.
Uh,
it's,
it's a rationalization that we don't spend too much money or too much time on.
We don't dwell on,
but we assume that it's futile.
And so we ignore it.
Uh,
another one is that it's very difficult,
uh,
to be a truly moral person.
I would have to give,
you know,
if,
if I really thought about what was the terrible things were happening,
I would,
I would have to give like 90% of my income,
uh,
and that,
that's so,
uh,
definitely not going to do that.
So maybe I just won't do anything.
And,
uh,
so,
people make,
where he illustrates in this book is there's a lot of casual thinking that we
use to justify,
uh,
to create an illusion of,
he calls it an illusion of innocence that we feel that were innocent
of any wrong doing for not supporting the poor.
Anyway,
this isn't a,
this is an appeal for charity.
So maybe you will donate or you probably some of you have already done that,
but I wanted you to because I think you're launching her.
I'm careers and um,
there's something,
uh,
they seem to be moral dilemmas abound.
[inaudible] I was impressed just looking at the New York Times this morning,
the stories that suggested moral dilemmas for young people who are launching out
on careers.
Uh,
one of them,
I'm just there reporting on the Pennsylvania primary,
which incidentally you heard Hillary Clinton won a 55 to 45.
Um,
but that's not what I was referring to.
It was that they said the voters thought the most important issue is the
economy,
the U s economy.
And I was thinking,
well,
what about Iraq and what about all the people that we are responsible,
we created the current situations there and people are dying everyday there.
Uh,
and we're concerned about the ECON.
It seemed to be something.
Next thing and the news this morning,
Rupert Murdoch,
we'll be buying Newsday,
the six largest regional paper in the United States for 580 million.
Somehow,
you know,
there's something bothersome about that store.
This guy is super rich.
Uh,
he's buying all the newspapers,
uh,
getting this is,
I mean,
he's a finance person,
right?
And he's gaining control over.
People read these newspapers as part of their recreation and relaxation.
And Newsday,
it's kind of a fun paper,
but it's under control of this finance billionaire.
Uh,
I don't know if that's a moral issue with next thing in today's paper,
US has 5% of the world's population and 25% of its prison inmates.
So something is maybe wrong.
And another thing that was in today's paper,
uh,
South African dock workers refused to unload a Chinese ship with weapons bound
for Robert Mugabe's re regime in Zimbabwe.
Uh,
and that the Chinese ship may return to China and without delivering,
uh,
this name,
well,
who are the dock workers?
This,
this is not funny.
This is not Rupert Murdoch.
This is humble people loading the docs and they have a union and they said,
we're not going to do this.
Uh,
we're not gonna support.
And Mugabi is a brutal efforts to suppress a,
a free election in his,
so you start to wonder,
are finance people moral or are they,
uh,
so,
um,
I,
I just give some,
I think that,
uh,
I don't know how you think,
but when I was your age,
I somehow wanted it perfect career that was morally right and,
uh,
important.
Uh,
so who has a perfect career?
I don't know.
I,
if I don't have an answer to that,
they're not going to propose an answer,
but let me just consider some names that come to mind.
Bill Gates.
Okay.
Now he is a business person who runs a tight financial ship and you may be aware
of how tight it is when you try to pirate one of his program or something.
And so he has a reputation for being a tough guy.
On the other hand,
he and Warren Buffet have set up the biggest,
uh,
transparently operated charitable foundation in the world and it has 38 point $7
billion.
So,
um,
how should we view,
I wonder how Peter Unger would view Bill Gates?
Uh,
he does have a,
uh,
what he's done on his house,
35 million on his house.
He does live a high style,
but you know,
should he have started out giving away 90% of his income when he was your age?
He wouldn't be making any money if he did that.
Right.
So I'm just thinking about,
uh,
I'm not saying what's right or wrong,
but I wanted to give one other example that comes to mind.
Have you heard of this guy?
Uh,
I'm trying to spell this right,
Mohammad Yunus.
Um,
he,
um,
was,
uh,
he went to Vanderbilt University and got a phd in economics in 1969.
Uh,
and then he became assistant professor of economics at Middle Tennessee State
University.
Um,
it sounds like a very ordinary career so far,
and it's actually,
it's good getting a phd,
but ordinary in a way.
But then he did something very important.
Uh,
in 1976,
he went back to his home country,
which was Bangladesh,
one of the poorest countries of the world.
And he founded a bank called the Grameen Bank.
Uh,
does anyone speak Bengali here?
But what does grand mean mean
there's no Bengali here?
Well,
I'm told that means,
uh,
of the village.
Uh,
and uh,
what he did is create a bank that made loans to poor people,
uh,
called micro finance.
Uh,
and,
um,
so the typical loan was made to a young woman who,
uh,
was on a desperate poverty and alone would be enough to buy some small item that
would start a business.
For example,
a pushcart that could serve hot food so she could then go and stand on a street
corner and sell some kind of food.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that can be a huge difference.
Having the money to buy a food cart,
uh,
and make her able to support her family.
Uh,
but no banks would,
no banks before,
uh,
the Grameen Bank would,
would,
uh,
would do that sort of thing.
And they claimed that they couldn't make money doing it,
but he apparently succeeded.
And so he wanted to know bell actually the Nobel peace prize went both to units
and the Grameen Bank,
uh,
and a couple of years ago.
So those are examples of people who had kind of a finance see careers.
If you looked at,
uh,
Muhammad Yunus,
in earlier years,
it might not look like a very morally Peter owner type moral career.
But I don't know what Peter Unger would say about Muhammad Yunus now.
He never,
we don't ever have any sense that he gave away 90% of his income to poor people,
but we'll look what he did.
So,
uh,
I don't know the answer to.
I guess what I'm getting at is that I don't know the answer to these moral
questions,
but I think that it's kind of a mistake to,
um,
to think that a career in finance is necessarily immoral and a,
if you read Peter Unger,
you get the impression that just about everyone is evading the moral issues.
Um,
maybe we're incapable of really behaving the way logic,
logical consideration of ethics would impel us to do.
Uh,
so hardly anyone is giving away 90% of their income.
so,
uh,
so I don't know where that leaves us exactly,
but,
um,
I guess,
uh,
what I wanted to do is leave open the possibility that a career in something
related to risk management can be a very meaningful,
uh,
career path for life.
Uh,
and I guess it comes back to the feeling that,
uh,
we live in a very risky world whose benefits are at this point shared very
unequally.
And,
uh,
I think that,
it's not the simple idea that you should be writing checks to.
UNICEF is not necessarily the final answer about what you should be doing with
your life.
And,
um,
uh,
somehow,
what we see in these examples,
I've gave both of Bill Gates,
Muhammad Yunus,
uh,
and,
and not setting them up as necessarily examples,
but,
uh,
but it's that a career that develops some idea,
that's well motivated,
uh,
can be,
a source of great meaning and purpose in life.
Um,
but what these people do is it seems to me as a,
um,
they,
they'd develop a career with some ultimate objective and somewhere along the
career it may seem that they're doing something unimportant or selfish.
Um,
but you have to judge it in the big context.
So at times I felt annoyed with Bill Gates when I had to pay for,
when I bought my second laptop and I had to buy a windows again.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think that,
what,
what were you really have to do is try to think of how,
how,
um,
I guess one's moral imperative might be one view is it might be that you should
develop some kind of human capital and some kind of long run plan for how you
are going to apply your human capital.
Uh,
and it doesn't necessarily mean being,
um,
uh,
satisfying this demands of UNICEF along the way.
We are people and we have a certain psychology,
I think we can get above her psychology to some extent.
Uh,
and you get above the drives of our psychology in moments of inspiration.
And I think developing a career,
uh,
can,
can be part of that anywhere.
I,
I've,
uh,
that was my inspiration inclusion now to this.
Uh,
and so I dunno what careers you will go into,
but,
um,
uh,
in the meantime,
we do have,
uh,
two more lectures.
Uh,
and I doubt that Larry Summers we'll be giving you advice about your careers,
but,
uh,
so I hope to see you again on Tuesday and Wednesday of next week.
[inaudible].